depuis plusieurs semaines le vendredi
c'est l'école de la rue pour le climat
mais les montréalais sont loin d'être
sommes paris londres hambourg
madrid des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes partout dans le monde veulent du
changement mais pas climatique est la
première à être stupéfaite de cette
mobilisation c'est elle et pour cause
l'été dernier elle a commencé tout seul
greta sundberg une grève de l'école pour
le climat devant le parlement suédois
mais son combat a emmené l'adolescente
de 16 ans loin des frontières de la
sphère à la conférence sur le climat en
pologne
elle marque une première fois les
esprits i want my ride of legends
combine ces phrases décoché comme des
flèches
elle est venue en train les prononcer à
davos avec et la résonance est immense
ici
ils tendent paris qui s'étend de le
sentir ressentir la peur qu'on fasse en
a tous les jours depuis notre naissance
au japon en passant par hong kong
de nouvelles greta partout dans le monde
ici mathieu poste radio canada mombert